oh the gym makes me feel sexy well you
know what else is sexy not being a
walking red
flag nobody cares about your abs if
you're the guy having a meltdown at
chilies
right I think people respect the gym cuz
there's a culture behind it you know
like Gym Rats they have T-shirts that
say beast mode and better sore than
sorry therapy people we need t-shirts we
need a shirt says no dad no
problem right like can't stop won't stop
crying
a I could have used some therapy as a
kid weird kid bed wetter oh yeah I wet
the bed every day while I was 13 years
old my mattress looked like a goddamn
coffee filter all right
woo I ruined a lot of sleepovers folks
yeah you start to run out of excuses
after a while now your friends's like
what happened here